your heart is an extraordinary machine
during your lifetime your hearts
muscular walls pump blood into blood
vessels branching throughout your body
[Music]
heart has four chambers two upper
chambers called the left and right atria
and two lower chambers called the left
and right ventricles contract in a
steady rhythm known as your heartbeat
during a normal heartbeat blood from
your tissues and lungs flows into your
atria then into your ventricles walls
inside your heart called the interatrial
and interventricular septum help keep
the blood on left and right sides from
mixing
[Music]
two valves sit like doors between your
atria and ventricles to prevent blood
from flowing backward into your atria
the tricuspid valve opens into your
right ventricle and the bicuspid valve
also known as the mitral valve opens
into your left ventricle strong thin
tissues called chordae tendineae hold
your valves in place during the forceful
contractions of your ventricles blood
leaving the ventricles passes through
another set of valves the pulmonary
valve between your right ventricle and
pulmonary trunk and the aortic valve
connecting your left ventricle and aorta
[Music]
in order to pump blood more efficiently
your heart muscle called myocardium is
arranged in a unique pattern three
layers of myocardium wrap around the
lower part of your heart they twist and
tighten in different directions to push
blood through your heart
when special cells called pacemaker
cells generate electrical signals inside
your heart the heart muscle cells called
myocytes contract as a group
[Music]
your heart is divided into left and
right halves which work together like a
dual pump on the right side of your
heart deoxygenated blood from your
body's tissues flows through large veins
called the superior and inferior vena
cava into your right atrium next the
blood moves into your right ventricle
which contracts and sends blood out of
your heart to your lungs to gather
oxygen and get rid of carbon dioxide on
the left side of your heart oxygen-rich
blood from your lungs flows through your
pulmonary veins into your left atrium
the blood then moves into your left
ventricle which contracts and sends
blood out of your heart through the
aorta to feed your cells and tissues
the first branches off your aorta are
the coronary arteries which supply your
heart muscle with oxygen and nutrients
at the top of your aorta arteries branch
off to carry blood to your head and arms
arteries branching from the middle and
lower parts of your aorta supply blood
to the rest of your body your heart
beats an average of 60 to 100 beats per
minute in that one minute your heart
pumps about five quarts of blood through
your arteries delivering a steady stream
of oxygen and nutrients all over your
body